[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSE PUPPIM DE OLIVEIRA: Hello,
I am Jose Puppim de Oliveira.
I am an MIT-UTM
business scholar.
This video shares some
lessons of my research
on urban innovation using case
of waste management in Penang,
Malaysia.
Urban innovation means
doing things differently
in the urban context.
Innovation is important for
improving urban services
in a context where many
cities around the world
face increasing
budgetary constraints.
Interaction among
different governmental and
non-governmental actors
are key to innovation.
Interactions can bring new
resources and knowledge
to solve urban problems
more effectively.
The waste sector in
Malaysia particularly
offers an interesting laboratory
for urban innovations.
The country has tried to improve
waste management effectiveness
in recent years, making a
series of institutional change,
such as decentralization
of waste management
at the federal level.
DR. MOHD PAUZE BIN
MOHAMAD TAHA: Previously,
the waste management
and public [INAUDIBLE]
is under the purview
of each government,
and being implemented
or being responsible
is under the local government.
Somehow, they have a difficulty
to provide sufficient funds
to manage.
At the same time do not
have expertise or manpower
to manage the solid
waste as previously.
Almost all the waste is
sent to the dumping ground.
Local government asking
federal government
to provide the fund for them.
We also want the
local government
to focus on other
areas of services.
So that's the reason why the
federal things is better.
So the responsibility
of managing the waste
is put on the federal
responsibility.
JOSE PUPPIM DE OLIVEIRA:
Peneng Island in Malaysia
decided to keep waste
management under local control.
GUEST SPEAKER: Actually, the
urban services department
is in charge of solid
waste management,
and also public cleansing is the
core business of the council.
The most challenging
part in Penang Island
is domestic waste.
Penang Island [INAUDIBLE]
around 550 tons of waste
is being disposed.
DR. LIM MAH HUI: The city
council spends about 40%
of its budget just
to dispose of waste.
GUEST SPEAKER: Our recycling
rate at the moment is 27%.
With the active role of the
recycling agent, the NGOs
and the environmental group,
in 1998, the domestic waste
around 700 tons.
Now it's really-- it's
around 440 tons per day.
So how we manage to reduce it?
In Penang, we had a very quite
active role of the stakeholders
doing recycling.
JOSE PUPPIM DE OLIVEIRA: Urban
innovations reduce the waste.
We are going to see two
of those initiatives
to understand how urban
innovations emerge
through different kinds of
institutional arrangements.
BROTHER SIOW EK: This the
Recycling and Education Center.
More important is education to
spread and actually encouraging
more people to do
recycling together.
And in Malasya, it's a long
time the recycling stopping it's
not part of the life
[? whole ?] practices yet.
So we have to set up the
proper infrastructure
to teach the residents how
recycling should be done,
so that when they
go back home, they
know how to actually
save the item
into the different category.
So we had about 20
were our volunteers.
In average, per
man, we are running
about 10 tons of material.
That cover plastic,
papers, metals.
All proceeds from
the recycling are all
channelled towards
the dialysis center.
LEE MEOW HONG: [INAUDIBLE]
Tzu Chi Dialysis Center,
actually, we started in 1997.
From the first day, it's
actually free of charge.
Everyone interested to know
how we survive for the past 18
years.
About 70% comes from
donation from the public.
Another nearly 30% comes
from our recycling.
BROTHER SIOW EK:
Recycling Education Center
is something very new.
When they equate recycling
center equal to rubbish center.
So when we want to
set up this center,
the resident community say,
no, we cannot allow a rubbish
center set up.
Then we have to explain
to them, we are not
setting up a rubbish center.
We are setting up
an education center.
No smell.
Line is clean.
JEFFERY HO: And there is
a mosquito-infested area.
Tzu Chi was willing to
come here to set it up,
so we work along with them.
BROTHER SIOW EK: We
actually work out
with the MBPP, the council.
They do actually facilitate.
They actually rent to us at
a very minimum rental cost.
Also, they are very supportive
of our recycling effort.
And at the same time,
by doing recycling,
we also reduce the
amount of rubbish
that they had to handle.
The whole country goes
for solid waste recycling.
So we're actually
two years ahead.
Go green, save lives.
LEE MEOW HONG: From
the recycling, besides,
we are doing
environmental protection.
We actually can save life.
MAGESWARI SANGARALINGAM: So
in terms of waste management,
it is not the right way
to just think of disposal.
We should try to
reduce the consumption
so that we will also reduce
the production of waste.
We are trying to promote
communities to be involved.
From the community, it goes
to the local government.
At least 45% to 50% is
organic waste or food waste.
How, in the first place, can you
reduce food waste, the kitchen
peelings or the green waste
which can go into composting.
JOSE PUPPIM DE OLIVEIRA:
Composting is the second case
of urban innovation.
You reach the private
sector partners
with this public sector
in civil society.
SOH YEW AUN: Most
of the problem is
that the people expect
the government to handle
the obvious.
Waste is not their problem.
It's government's problem.
How people look at food waste,
because to them, it is a waste.
But to the world, it
is actually a resource.
Most recycling companies
don't survive for long,
because the cost is too
high to do recycling.
And the economic return
sort of value is too low.
The only way for them to make
money is, of course, then
to look at government subsidies,
looking at government credit
mechanisms.
We have come up with
something that we know
that is economically feasible.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
CHIN KEE WONG: Methodist Boys'
School, a few years back, we
were approached by
one of our old boys,
who also happened to be
a councilor in the city
council in Penang.
So he came up with the idea
of turning the school green.
All canteen waste,
especially food waste,
churned up in the
machine and converted
into enzymes, which later we
converted into fertilizer.
And that fertilizer, we
brought to our eco-green farm.
NG CHUN WEI: We have a
daily schedule for Monday
to Friday for all
these food [INAUDIBLE]
to collect the food waste
from the canteen just
to be processed here.
WONG CHIEW LEE: We
have the fruit section.
We also have the herbal
section, kitchen remedies.
Over the other
side, you will find
that we have this rainwater
harvesting system.
So this is some collaboration
with USM, [NON-ENGLISH].
SOH YEW AUN: In Penang Hills,
we deal with the end product
differently.
We ferment the food
waste here itself,
without taking back
to the factories.
And then we use the fermented
food waste to treat sewage.
And the [INAUDIBLE] has got no
smell and no oil accumulation,
no grease accumulation.
If you ask me, I
think a lot of things
work better on a small
scale than on a large scale.
Everybody has to cooperate.
You can develop the best
machines in the world,
but if the people
don't cooperate,
the machine's not
going to run by itself.
Food waste doesn't get
separated by itself.
You need people.
Everybody has to
chip in some way.
And this is where we are
going on with the schools,
to start teaching the students
of the importance of actually
separating your food
waste and making sure
that they're going to
the correct places.
JOSE PUPPIM DE OLIVEIRA: Three
main lessons from the case.
First, innovation
capabilities were
created by involving
various stakeholders.
Second, broad
stakeholder involvement
brought resources, like
knowledge and finance
from various sources.
These would not be possible if
a stakeholder was working alone.
Third, innovations were
able to connect waste
with other issues,
such as health, sewage
treatment, and education.
Innovation can overcome problems
of collective action, where
many stakeholders
must work together.
MAGESWARI SANGARALINGAM:
There should
be awareness amongst
the communities
on how to reduce the waste, and
also in terms of the industry.
And so there are lot of
players in the field of waste
management which everyone
has to take part in.
JOSE PUPPIM DE OLIVEIRA: The
state and local authorities
have helped to scale up such
initiatives by providing
support to coordinate
the different efforts
from federal government,
civil society,
and link them with citizens.
MUBARAK BIN JUNUS: We
still feel that there
is something to be done more.
We already come up to the policy
in line with the federal policy
to come up with the
mechanism of collections.
We are now going to use the
same mechanism as federal,
what they are doing.
We are going to
improvise this according
to our own local environment.
JOSE PUPPIM DE
OLIVEIRA: A combination
of top-down efforts
from governments
to support initiatives of
bottom-up urban innovation
brings the right combination
to nurture broad transformation
in urban services delivery.
MAGESWARI SANGARALINGAM:
The way you're disposing it,
whether you're landfilling
or you're incinerating,
or you're just dumping,
it's all causing problems
for the climate, too, because
of the greenhouse gas emissions.
ANTHONY CAPON: How can we make
a city suitable for our bodies
and our health?
We have designed and
managed cities often
in the interest of
motorcars, rather than
in the interests of people.
We need to rethink the city
in the interest of people.
MUBARAK BIN JUNUS:
Even though there
is some initiative
being done, but still
the mindset still
needs to be changed.
DR. YUEH-KWONG LEONG: The
current concept of development
is the more buildings they have,
the more industries they have,
the more developed you are,
the better you will become.
But they have not
factored in, actually,
the cost in terms of pollution,
in terms of traffic congestion.
JOSE PUPPIM DE OLIVEIRA:
Creating the capabilities
to innovate in governments
and civil society
is crucial to combating global
problems such as climate
change, which requires a higher
degree of collective action
to design and manage the
cities of the future.
This will require
innovation in our thinking
about how we carry
out urban development.
[MUSIC PLAYING]